[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und marietas lomka guten Abend
müsste man für einen Film die Rolle
eines brutalen Kriegsverbrechers und
Mafiosi besetzen wäre JEF gehen die
prigoshin eine Idealbesetzung und
genauso passt der in das System von
Putin der nicht nur auf die regulären
Streitkräfte sondern auch auf private
Armeen setzt
der Gründer der berüchtigten
Söldnergruppe Wagner meldet sich häufig
über Social Media zu Wort oft tobend und
Fluchen was ist mit seinen Tiraden gegen
das russische Verteidigungsministerium
auf sich hat ist schwer einzuschätzen
aber sein neuestes Video in dem man mit
dem Abzug aus bachmut droht hat eine
eigene Qualität
und was immer sich hinter den Kulissen
des russischen Machtapparats abspielt
nach Geschlossenheit sieht das nicht aus
Christian Kirsch und Christoph Wiesel
berichten
weite Teile von bachmut im Osten der
Ukraine wollen sie erobert haben oder
das was von der Stadt noch übrig ist
Söldner der wagnergruppe unterwegs
zwischen Trümmern im Auftrag Russlands
allerdings es geht kaum noch voran
erbitterte Widerstand der ukrainischen
Armee Söldner Chef prigoschin genannt
Putins Koch fordert immer wieder mehr
Unterstützung vom Kreml beschimpft die
Armeeführung verlangte Waffen und
Munition doch sein jüngster ordinärer
Wutausbruch hat eine neue Dimension
70% zu wenig
wo ist die verdammte Munition schaut ihr
Ärsche
sie kamen hierher als Freiwillige und
sie sterben damit ihr euer Leben
genießen könnt in euren schönen
holzvertäfelten Büros
der Verteidigungsminister und sein
generalstaatschef lassen beide die
Söldner im Dienst des Krimml ausbluten
Minister schöllgut eigentlich
Katastrophenschützer fehlt die
Unterstützung russischer Generäle
generell garasimos Winteroffensive ist
gescheitert für beide ist brigoshin der
machtvolle seltener Chef Werkzeug und
Konkurrent was bezweckt mit dem
Wutausbruch auf der einen Seite hat er
das Versprechen gegeben das Erwachen
befreit er ist dafür aber immer abhängig
gewesen auch schon in der Vergangenheit
von den Zulieferungen der russischen
Streitkräfte an Munition an anderen
versorgungsgegenständen und er kann
seinen Auftrag quasi nicht erfüllen und
damit auch sozusagen seine politische
Macht die er sich damit erkämpft hat in
kremme gar nicht halten und ich glaube
das ist eine Verzweiflungstat als eine
sehr berechten tat
mehr als 100 Tote pro Tag sagt Kiew
verzeichneten Flieger
sind unsere Wagner Leute die heute
starben
das Blut ist noch frisch filmt sie alle
und jetzt hört gut zu ihr Arschlöcher
das sind Väter das sind Söhne und diese
Ärsche die uns keine Munition geben
die sollen in der Hölle schmoren
heute drohte billigaschin seine Truppen
in 5 Tagen aus bachmut abzuziehen
das er seine Truppen jetzt zurückziehen
würde ist relativ unwahrscheinlich dafür
ist er in seiner Position und auch in
seiner Reputation in Russland so stark
vom Kreml abhängig würde er die Soldaten
zurückziehen die kremme die die Wagner
Soldaten würde das ja bedeuten dass die
russischen Truppen auf einmal alleine
kämpfen müssen und das würde zu deutlich
höheren Verlusten führen was wiederum in
der russischen Bevölkerung auch im
Kremmen nicht gut ankommen würde
die Wagner seltener offenbar Teil eines
massiven Machtkampf in Russlands Militär
es geht um Macht und Einfluss und immer
auch um Leben und Tod
nach Deutschland die alte Weisheit
streiten sich zwei freut sich der Dritte
kann zwar auch in der Politik zutreffen
ist aber kein Selbstläufer das zeigt das
neue ZDF Politbarometer dass ich Grüne
und FDP in den letzten Wochen immer
wieder so massiv ineinander verhakten
und der Kanzler da eher in der Rolle des
moderierenden Schiedsrichter erschien
hat ihm und der SPD in den Umfragen
jedenfalls nicht genutzt eine Mehrheit
der Befragten ist mit der Arbeit der
Bundesregierung insgesamt unzufrieden
und Olaf Scholz sinkt auf seinen bisher
schlechtesten Wert bei der persönlichen
Beurteilung das gleiche gilt für Robert
Habeck wie der Wirtschaftsminister und
seine Partei mit diesem Stimmung tief
umgehen betrachtet Patricia Wiedemeier
ein kurzer Gruß für die warteenden
Journalisten mehr nicht Robert Habeck in
diesen Tagen worttag gehetzt unter Druck
heute morgen in Berlin Fachkonferenz zum
Thema grüne Wärme für alle eigentlich
ein wohlfühltermin Harbeck wirkt hier
für die wärmewende verspricht soziale
Abfederung gibt sich kämpferisch
das Wecken vor einem Problem macht es
nur größer wollen wir diejenigen sein
die trotz besseren Wissens sich in die
eigene Tasche lügen
dann gehe ich raus
erklären die Bürger mitnehmen Ihnen die
Ängste nehmen und vor allem die Vorteile
wie geringere Energiekosten hervorheben
genau das versucht habe heute aber viel
zu spät meint der Politikwissenschaftler
Korte
wo liegt also der Vorteil dass wir uns
gerade zu freuen auch Veränderungen und
diesen Vorteil ist ein kommunikativer
Vorteil zunächst mal den hat er
vernachlässigt in der Vergangenheit so
dass aus der Anmutung einer
macher-partei plötzlich eine
verbotspartei geworden ist wieder
verbotspartei kein neues Phänomen für
die Grünen schon vor langer Zeit war es
das Thema fünf Mark für den Dieter
Benzin dann kam der Veggie day
Urlaubsflüge sollten teurer Inlandsflüge
ganz verboten werden jetzt wollen die
Grünen angeblich fossile Heizungen
verbieten das was dort stattfindet ist
der Versuch von einer bestimmten Lobby
getrieben durch die Bild-Zeitung mit
Falschinformation mit Fehlinformation
dagegen Sturm zu laufen
das mag kurzfristig Erfolg haben meine
Erfahrung ist in so einer Situation ist
das beste Rezept ruhig Kurs zu halten
ruhig Kurs halten nicht so einfach wenn
die Rückendeckung der beiden anderen
Koalitionspartner fehle so die grüne
Fraktionsvorsitzende momentan erleben
wir eher dass viele sich dann schlanken
Fuß machen dass sie zwar behaupten sie
sein für Klimaschutz aber eigentlich
gegen jede konkrete einzelne Maßnahme
kämpfen die mehr Klimaschutz bringt und
in der Diskussion und das Gebäude
Energiegesetz erleben wir sogar von
demokratischen Mitbewerbern dass sie
Behauptungen aufstellen die nicht mal
Stimmen es gibt viele Gründe für das
derzeitig schlechte Image der Grünen und
das obwohl habe ich das Thema
Energiesicherheit im Winter doch gut
gemanagt habe es gibt für habe ich immer
die Chance zum Comeback weil auch vor
den Rahmenbedingungen eines vermutlich
heißen Sommers das Bewusstsein dass wir
klimamäßig etwas machen müssen dass wir
enkelfähige Politik betreiben wieder
zunehmen wird doch ein Comeback von
Harbeck hängt auch davon ab wie er mit
dem Vorwurf der Vetternwirtschaft rund
um seinen Staatssekretär reichen umgeht
klare Ansagen heute vom Kanzler aus dem
fernen Afrika er hat gesagt dass
Entscheidungen die falsch gelaufen sind
und die kritisierbar sind korrigiert
werden müssen das ist passiert und ich
gehe davon aus dass auch alles andere
entsprechend der Regeln die wir haben
erfolgen wird habe ich selber lange
nicht mehr so beliebt wie noch vor einem
Jahr versucht beim solargipfel heute
Nachmittag alles klein zu reden meine
persönlichen Umfragewerte stehen
überhaupt nicht zu Debatte ist nicht das
worauf ich gucke sondern auf das was
passiert im Haus
in einem Staatsamt und da möchte ich
gerne so agieren da wo Fehler passieren
soll man sie nicht vernuscheln
vertuscheln oder Weg reden aber wenn
keine Fehler gemacht worden sein müsste
man das auch benennen so habe ich jetzt
wolle er seine Arbeit machen
das neue Politbarometer gibt es dann
gleich am Ende der Sendung und natürlich
jetzt schon online auf ZDF heute und mit
den Personalquerelen in havix
Ministerium geht es jetzt bei dir erst
noch mal weiter eins ja vor diesem
Hintergrund schreibt der Aufsichtsrat
der Deutschen Energieagentur Dehner den
Chefposten des bundesunternehmens neu
aus dies beschloss das Aufsichtsgremium
heute wie die Energieagentur in Berlin
mitteilte Anlass der Neuausschreibung
ist dass der eigentlich vorgesehene neue
Geschäftsführer Trauzeuge von
Staatssekretär Graichen ist
die Überlegungen von
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Harbeck für
einen niedrigeren industriestrompreis
sind seit Tagen in der Diskussion
Finanzminister Lindner hat sich ja
bereits kritisch geäußert heute nun hat
Harbeck das Konzept vorgelegt dass
energieintensive Industrieunternehmen
beim Strompreis entlasten und so die
internationale Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
steigern soll demnach sollen bis 2030
bis zu 30 Milliarden Euro aus dem
Wirtschaft stabilisierungsfond zur
Verfügung gestellt werden um diesen
Unternehmen einen Strompreis von 6 Cent
pro Kilowattstunde zu garantieren für
80% ihres Verbrauchs
das Bundeskanzler Scholz heute in Kenia
zu Gast war wurde vorhin schon kurz
angesprochen Kenia ist der wichtigste
Handelspartner Deutschlands in Ostafrika
und hat aus Sicht von Scholz auch ein
großes Potenzial an Fachkräften für
viele Bereiche der deutschen Wirtschaft
zudem ging es um die Zusammenarbeit bei
den Themen Energie und Klimaschutz Kenia
gewinnt nach Regierungsangaben und 90%
seine Stroms aus erneuerbaren Energien
die Weltgesundheitsorganisation WHO
stuft die corona-pandemie nach mehr als
drei Jahren nun nicht mehr als
internationalen gesundheitsnotstand ein
damit ist die höchste Alarmstufe
aufgehoben aber das bedeutet nicht dass
covid 19 als Bedrohung vorbei sein der
WHO wurden nach eigenen Angaben bislang
weltweit fast sieben Millionen
Todesfälle gemeldet tatsächlich sei aber
von mindestens 20 Millionen auszugehen
in Serbien ist es nach dem Angriff in
einer Schule mit neun Toten erneut zu
einer Schießerei gekommen südlich der
Hauptstadt Belgrad erschoss ein
21-jähriger acht Menschen 14 weitere
wurden verletzt der Täter soll das Feuer
gestern Namen späten Abend aus dem Auto
heraus eröffnet haben offenbar nach
einem Streit die Polizei nahm den
mutmaßlichen Schützen daraufhin heute
morgen fest Serbiens Staatschef wucic
kündigte Folge der beiden Angriffe eine
fast vollständige Entwaffnung von
Privatpersonen an
endet die Operation golden OP die
Operation goldener Reichsapfel unter
diesen Code bereitete sich die britische
Krone seit zig Jahren minoziös auf eine
erneute Krönung vor die letzte ist 70
Jahre her und da ist man ja sozusagen
aus der Übung allerdings haben die
Royals mit der Beerdigung von Königin
Elisabeth gerade erst gezeigt dass sie
Welt Ereignis können da saß jeder
Schritt und jedes Symbol und es werden
auch morgen sicher wieder weltweit
hunderte Millionen Menschen zusehen wie
einer Theateraufführung auf globaler
Bühne Hilke Petersen berichtet aus
London am Vorabend der Krönung von
kurz vor Krönung der König trifft das
Volk und das macht hier an der
Absperrung ziemlich glücklich das
Charles seit acht Monaten einen guten
Job macht finden die meisten und sind
darüber auch ein bisschen erstaunt war
doch eigentlich immer der etwas
schrullige Prince of Wales
[Applaus]
[Musik]
um die Umwelt macht obwohl inzwischen
stimmen die meisten im Zug das alles ist
ein Teil des Lebens geworden wie das
Postamt so funktioniert Großbritannien
plötzlich König zu sein das Amt scheint
den Mann zu verändern vielleicht setzt
die Krönung noch einen drauf der ganze
Rummel jedenfalls Rampenlicht für König
Charles den dritten dieser hier vom
Buckingham Palast inszeniert von einer
Videokünstlerin die Polizei lässt die
Kutsche irrtümlich durch hier hilft der
legendäre Humor
ich bin sehr sicher der echte König hat
Sinn für Humor ich habe ihn mal
getroffen und er sagte zu mir alles Gute
von irgendwas muss man leben heißt du
eine living
das ist total cool wir haben kein
Königshaus in Amerika es ist großartig
spektakuläre Unterhaltung auch das lässt
die britische Monarchie weltweit so
bedeutend erscheinen morgen wieder wenn
Charles und Camilla hier gekrönt werden
der Wechsel in der Thronfolge macht die
Gegner mobiler sie klagen lauter die
koloniale Vergangenheit der Krone an und
ihren Reichtum das Charles morgen zum
ersten Mal alle dazu einlädt den
traditionellen Eid auf den König zu
schwören hier kann das volksna Gemeinte
Angebot keiner annehmen
für den Staat und seine Führung es ist
nicht nur ein unterhaltungsspektakel und
es macht unbequeme Fragen auf für die
Leute denn das ist viel verlangt von
Ihnen wenn es so viel Ungleichheit gibt
das so viel Unglück so ein instabiles
Land
das wird die Herausforderung für Charles
als König denn der Monarch ist das
Symbol der Einheit die Fliehkräfte sind
groß im Königreich so wie in den
Commonwealth starten im Palast treffen
sich alle am Tag vor der Krönung
weil Charles der nachhaltige ist und der
nachdenkliche versteht er sich auf
Europa gut fürs Königreich nach dem
brexit
neues die Regierung erwartet von ihm zu
helfen die alten Verbindung zur Europa
zu erneuern die sind ebenso wichtig wie
die zum Commonwealth
der König ist ganz Mensch dem auch mal
die Nerven durchgehen wenn beim
Unterschreiben eines Thronfolge
Dokuments der Füllfederhalter schmiert
das verdammte Ding
[Musik]
Camilla unauffällige Ruhe in Person die
Haltung machte sie nach und nach
akzeptabel im Königreich dass sie morgen
gekrönt wird vor Jahren noch undenkbar
Charles und Camilla beide aufgelegt zum
Spaß vor dem langen krönungswochenende
als Ansager im Zugverkehr
[Musik]
das wollen wir nach vertiefen den Blick
auf die Krönung morgen unsere Hilfe
Petersen nicke beim Begräbnis der Queen
das ist jetzt nicht lange her da hieß es
noch die Nation hat sich noch mal
untergehakt also hinter dem Sarg
versammelt was wird das morgen für ein
Tag in welcher Stimmungslage gehen die
Briten da rein
also es gibt Umfragen wo nach zwei
Drittel sich für die Krönung nicht oder
nicht besonders interessieren das sieht
hier heute Abend auf der Prachtstraße da
mal nicht so aus hier hinter mir Campen
all die die eine Poleposition an den
Absperrungen haben wollen die feiern
dass Ereignis natürlich total aber es
ist morgen auch ein Tag wo die Gegner
und die sind lauter geworden seit dem
Tod der Queen sich hier treffen und
sagen können not my King das ist nicht
mein König wir sind eigentlich
diejenigen die eine Republik wollen es
ist ein Tag an dem alle auf London
gucken werden 100 Staatsoberhäupter sind
unter den 2200 Gästen die in dem
krönungsgottesdienst in der Westminster
absetzen werden
um Zauber die Queen hielt sich der
strickt dann die Maxime des großen
Staats Theoretikers Walter badged die
Magie der Krone wirken nur wenn man sie
vom Tageslicht fernhält aber wenn wir
uns jetzt Schatz angucken der ist ja
schon vollständig ausgeleuchtet bevor er
überhaupt die Krone aufgesetzt bekommt
wird er das anders machen sich mehr
äußern politischer sein
erstmal gilt der Monarch hat politisch
neutral zu sein er hat in seiner
Antrittsrede als König dem Volk gesagt
man könne von ihm erwarten dass er sich
ein bisschen zurückzöge aus dem was er
jahrelang als Prinz von Wales mit seinen
Stiftungen für Umwelt für
sozialpolitische Dinge getan hat er
könne das nicht mehr schaffen
tatsächlich ist es so er gilt als
Workaholic und wenn man auf seine Agenda
guckt auf seine Termine dann ist es so
dass sehr viel sozialpolitisches dabei
ist er besucht Wärmestuben Tafeln er ist
sehr gerne unterwegs in migrantischen
Communitys und auch bei anderen
Religionen das wird man auch im
krönungsgottesdienst morgen sehen die
Feiern mit und sie wirken auch mit und
er hat ein politisches Profil muss man
sagen und das hat halt damit zu tun dass
er so lange der Thronfolger der Prinz
von Wales war wo er das natürlich
vielleicht machen konnte
weil ja gerade mit Camilla zu besuchen
in Deutschland und dieser Besuch der
wurde ja auch so gewertet dass die
britische Regierung versucht die
Beziehung zu Europa zu verbessern nach
dem brexit das klang eben bei den Stück
auch schon ein bisschen an wird das eine
der Hauptaufgaben dieses Königs sein
werden
ja der Experte den wir da eben gehört
haben der sagt das ist die Erwartung der
Regierung dass er da verloren gegangen
durch brexit verloren gegangene Bande
wieder knüpft und tatsächlich ist es so
seine ersten Staatsbesuche führten nicht
ins Commonwealth nicht nach Kanada nicht
nach Australien sondern Frankreich war
geplant dass viel der wegen der Proteste
dann aus sie fuhren dann noch
Deutschland oder reisten nach
Deutschland und das war der erste
Staatsbesuch
er ist eine geeignete Figur vermutlich
aus sich der Regierung um diese
Verbindung wieder aufzuwärmen und so
schwierige Dinge zum Beispiel wie die
Verhandlung mit der EU zum
nordirlandprotokoll da ging es um die
handelsregelungen mit Nordirland die im
Februar stattgefunden hatten Ursula von
der Leyen hat das lange vorbereitet mit
regisseuna den britischen
Premierminister und das galt dann als
ein geglücktes Stück Politik und als
dann anschließend Ursula von der Leyen
auch noch zum Besuch im Palast war und
es solche Fotos gab ist er gerade von
konservativer und brexit Hardliner Seite
sehr kritisiert worden dass das ein
Stück Politik sei was sozusagen nicht in
die konservative Linie passte also das
zeigt sehr deutlich er muss da
tatsächlich sehr aufpassen wenn er in
Gewässer kommt in denen er politisch
ausgedeutet werden könnte danke schon
Hilke für diese Analyse und
Einschätzungen nach London
und jetzt geht es bei dir noch mal
weiter mit Wirtschaft das Neugeschäft
der deutschen Industrie ist im März
deutlich eingebrochen um rund zehn
Prozent sanken die Aufträge im März im
Vergleich zum Vormonat hat der
Statistische Bundesamt mitgeteilt soweit
die Statistik Stefanie berrett wie sind
diese Zahlen einzuordnen ja also rein
faktisch hat die deutsche Industrie ein
derart starken Auftragseinbruch zuletzt
vor drei Jahren zu Beginn der Pandemie
gesehen deshalb lassen die Zahlen auch
heute so aufhorchen ökonomen hatten zwar
mit einem Rückgang von 2% nicht aber mit
einem Minus von 10,7% gerechnet denn im
Februar verbuchte die deutsche
Wirtschaft ja noch ein dickes Auftrags
plus auch die Lieferengpässe waren
zuletzt kein Thema mehr doch jetzt sind
die üppigen Auftragspolster abgearbeitet
und neue Aufträge kommen offenbar
schleppen da rein ein deutliches
wahnsignal für die konjunkturelle
Entwicklung
und wieso ist das so wie lässt sich die
Situation erklären also die europäische
Wirtschaft gerät zunehmend von vielen
Seiten in den Zangen griff die
steigenden Zinsen verteuern
Investitionen gleichzeitig ziehen Banken
die Daumenschrauben bei der
Kreditvergabe an und jetzt sehen sich
Unternehmen mit einem gigantischen
amerikanischen Subventionsprogramm
konfrontiert das gute Chancen hat die
europäischen Produktionskosten drastisch
zu unterbieten auch die hohen
Energiekosten zehren an der
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit deshalb kam hier
heute der angekündigte preisdeckel für
Industriestrom durchaus gut an der DAX
beschließt die Woche mit einem Plus von
knapp anderthalb Prozent bei
15.961 Punkten weitere Impulse könnten
aus den USA kommen dort zeigt sich die
Wirtschaft trotz steigender Zinsen
robust und der Job Mutter brummt auch
weiterhin Stefan vielen Dank
nach Neapels vorzeitigem Sieg bei der
italienischen Fußballmeisterschaft ist
es in der Stadt zu massiven
Ausschreitungen gekommen mehr als 200
Menschen wurden teils schwer verletzt
und ein Mann starb durch
Schussverletzungen gestern in Udine der
SSC Neapel zurück auf dem italienischen
fußball-drohen das lange warten hat ein
Ende Ekstase bei Anhängern Spielern bei
Trainers balletti 33 Jahre nach dem
letzten Meistertitel schafft eine Truppe
der Namenlosen die Überraschung in
italienischen Fußball zweiter Matchball
verwandelt Udine geht zwar in Führung
aber dann schlägt wieder er zu Viktor
und Siemens Wolfsburger top Torjäger der
Serie Abend mit seinem Ausgleich in der
52 Minute das reicht die
süditalienermeister 5 Spieltage vor
Saisonende zum dritten Mal in der
Vereinsgeschichte und während sie in
Udine den Platz stürmen erlebt nie Apel
bereits den Ausnahmezustand jubelextase
aber auch Chaos mehr als 200 verletzte
und am Rande der Feier lichkeiten sogar
ein toter nach Schießerei dies die
ernüchternde Bilanz des Abends Neapel
erfolgreich und chaotisch nicht nur der
Titel erinnert an die goldenen Zeiten
mit Diego Maradona
ein besonderes Spektakel gibt es dieses
Wochenende auf der Elbe zu sehen der
Hamburger Hafen feiert seinen 834
Geburtstag die Einlaufparade mit
großsegern Museums und feuerwehrschiffen
eröffnete heute das größte Hafenfest der
Welt in den nächsten Tagen können sich
die Besucher auf viele Feierlichkeiten
auf und am Wasser freuen insgesamt
werden etwa eine Million Gäste erwartet
das neue ZDF Politbarometer war in
unserer Sendung ja schon Thema die
Umfrageergebnisse im Einzelnen
präsentiert ihn jetzt Matthias Fornoff
guten Abend willkommen zum
Politbarometer
Rekorde sind ja eigentlich
erstrebenswert jedenfalls wenn es
positive sind schlechter gegen wenn man
sich selbst unterbietet so wie die
Bundesregierung in unserer aktuellen
Umfrage noch nie waren die Befragten so
unzufrieden mit der Ampelkoalition wie
jetzt
43 Prozent der Befragten meinen die
Bundesregierung mache ihre Arbeit eher
gut und die Hälfte aber 51 Prozent
attestieren ihr schlechter Arbeit
drei Parteien regieren und haben
mindestens genauso viele Vorstellungen
was für das Land das Beste ist
die Tage in den die stärkste Kraft
selbstverständlich Taktgeber der
Regierung war scheinen vorbei die SPD
stellt den Kanzler und sich selbst
hinten an
nur 22% glauben dass die SPD ihre
politischen Vorstellungen in der
Regierung stark durchsetzt
70% glauben das nicht anders werden die
Grünen bewertet 51% halten sie für
durchsetzungsstark
44% nicht dass die FDP ihre Positionen
in der Koalition stark durchsetzt meinen
insgesamt 42 Prozent
51% sehen das anders
egal wer den Ton angibt die meisten
Befragten erwarten dass sie Ampel bis
zur nächsten Bundestagswahl 2025 halten
wird stand jetzt hätte sie aber keine
Mehrheit mehr denn wenn nächsten Sonntag
wirklich Bundestagswahl wäre könnte die
SPD sich leicht verbessern und käme auf
19% + 1 die Union wäre weiter deutlich
vorne
30%, wenn auch mit leichten Verlusten
grüne 17 Prozent minus 1 fdp6 AFD 15
beide unverändert die Linke gewinnt
leichter zu 5 Prozent damit wäre sie im
Bundestag vertreten anders als bei
unserer letzten Umfrage
kommen wir zu unserer Top Ten also der
Bewertung der zehn wichtigsten
Politikerinnen und Politiker nach
Sympathie und Leistung der Verdruss
macht sich auch hier bemerkbar die
Beliebtheitswerte sind insgesamt so
niedrig wie selten auf der Skala von
plus 5 bis -5 bleibt Sarah Wagenknecht
das Schlusslicht minus 1,3 etwas besser
als zuletzt
davor nennt sie Faser -0,6 Friedrich
Merz -0,4 und Markus Söder ebenfalls
minus 0,4 alle etwas schlechter
Christian Lindner unverändert mit -0,3
genauso wie Karl Lauterbach Robert
Habeck erneut etwas schlechter -0,2
Annalena baerbock mit leichten Verlusten
0,1
auch Olaf Scholz verliert leicht und
liegt bei 0,1 für den Kanzler und
Vizekanzler Harbeck sind das ihre bisher
schlechtesten Werte
weiter deutlich vor allen anderen Boris
Pistorius 1,7 ebenfalls mit leichten
Verlusten
das politische Personal steht unter
Beobachtung nicht zuletzt beim Thema
Klima Lösungen müssen her so viel ist
klar ein Tempo der Umsetzung herrscht
aber Uneinigkeit
die Umsetzungen von Klimaschutzmaßnahmen
geht zu schnell dass man 34 Prozent 41%
finden dagegen es geht zu langsam voran
20 Prozent bewerten das Tempo als gerade
richtig dass die Klimaschutzmaßnahmen zu
schnell vorangebracht werden meinen
Verein die Anhänger von Union FDP und am
deutlichsten die der AFD
einig sind sich die Befragten wenn es um
die sogenannten
klimakleber geht ihre Aktionen hält eine
große Mehrheit für nicht zielführend für
den Klimaschutz werde so wenig oder gar
nichts erreicht mein mehr als 90 Prozent
eine Chance für den Klimaschutz könnte
der Umstieg auf mehr ÖPNV sein in dieser
Woche ist das 49 Euro Ticket an den
Start gegangen die allermeisten finden
das Ticket gut
57% gehen davon aus dass mit dem Ticket
künftig deutlich mehr Menschen Busse und
Bahnen nutzen werden 41 glauben das
nicht
Optimismus zeigt sich vor allem bei den
jüngeren Befragten aber mehrheitlich
über alle Altersgruppen hinweg
und wir schauen noch kurz ins Ausland in
die Türkei wenige Monate nach den
verheerenden Erdbeben dazu in
wirtschaftlichen Krisenzeiten wählen die
Türken in gut einer Woche ihren
Präsidenten
wenn der amtierende Präsident Erdogan
erneut gewählt würde finden das nur
sechs Prozent der Deutschen gut 81
Prozent würden eine Wiederwahl kritisch
sehen
auch in Deutschland leben viele
Wahlberechtigte sie können bei den
türkischen Konsulaten schon jetzt ihre
Stimme abgeben die Wahl gilt als
spannend wie lange nicht und wird auch
hier in Deutschland genau beobachtet
werden
das war unser Bericht über die Stimmung
im Land die Grafiken und alle
Informationen zu unseren Umfragen finden
Sie wie immer im ZDF textabseite 165 in
der ZDF heute App und auf ZDF heute.de
wie die repräsentativen Umfragen der
Forschungsgruppe Wahlen Zustandekommen
Informationen zur Methodik und zu den
Qualitätsstandards finden Sie unter
politbarometer.zdf.de
am 11 mai gibt es ein Politbarometer
extra zur Bürgerschaftswahl in Bremen
und das nächste reguläre Politbarometer
folgt am 26 Mai nach dem Wetter folgt
hier gleich die heute-show vielen Dank
für Ihr Interesse Ihnen noch einen
entspannten Abend auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ziemlich turbulent
ging es heute durch den Tag mit Schauern
und Gewittern teilweise gab es sogar
Hagel mit zwei bis drei Zentimeter
Korngröße viel Regen und Sturmböen das
ganze zeigt sich auf unserem radarfilm
so sah es heute tagsüber aus im Norden
zog es als erstes auf und dann ostwärts
und hier im Süden da ging es dann vor
allem in den Abendstunden zur Sache
München hat es etwa vor einer Stunde
erwischt und hier sehen wir uns noch
einmal wie es aufzieht und einmal nach
Osten zieht diese Schauer und Gewitter
ziehen nun im Laufe der Nacht weiter
nach Osten Richtung Bayerischer Wald und
dann wird es auch weniger schauen wir
uns die Übersichtskarte an also im
Nordosten kommt der Regen in der zweiten
Nachthälfte an und dort wird es auch
längere Zeit regnen sonst gibt's noch
hier die letzten Schauer und Gewitter
können auch noch kräftig ausfallen aber
von Westen er lässt es nach hier
befindet sich sogar Nebel Temperaturen
gehen zurück auf vier Grad an der Ostsee
zum Beispiel hier wird ein strammer
Ostwind dementsprechend kommt die
deutlich kühlere Luft an als zum
Beispiel im Südosten Richtung Bayern am
mildesten mit 12 Grad morgen dann
weiterer Regen im Nordosten der hält
sich durchaus noch eine Weile zum
Nachmittag wird es dann weniger sonst
bilden sich Schauer und Gewitter
zwischen Erzgebirge und Alpenrand Blitz
und Donner gibt es auch im Westen aber
nur zwischendurch einmal ansonsten ist
es hier relativ freundlich vor allem
nach Südwesten hin die Temperaturen
erreichen höchste Werte von nur 9 Grad
an der Ostsee hier immer noch also ein
strammer Ostwind ansonsten aber deutlich
wärmer mit 23 bis 24 Grad nach Südwesten
hin aber häufig Temperaturen um die 20
Grad Marke die nächsten Tage am Sonntag
kommt kräftige Schauer und Gewitter aus
dem Südwesten auf ja und die können
wieder im unwetterbereich Liegen
ansonsten nach Osten ist es deutlich
Trockner und freundlicher mit
Sonnenschein bei 14 bis 23 Grad Sonntag
gibt es ähnliches Wetter aber die
Gewitter sind nicht ganz so heftig
Temperatur Niveau bleibt eh nicht 15 bis
22 Grad und Dienstag ist ebenfalls
durchwachsen kommen Sie gut durch die
Schauer und Gewitter und damit wünsche
ich Ihnen einen schönen Abend